[Musique]
je vais pas vous mentir les jambes c'est
un grand jour c'est un grand jour parce
que je viens de recevoir mes deux iphone
l'iphone 10 aces et l'iphone 10s nax ici
tout beau bien emballé bien empaqueté
bien protégés je suis super content
parce que ces deux smartphones me
faisait franchement de reuil
les deux modèles en 64 giga donc c'est
plutôt une excellente nouvelle donc ce
qu'on va faire je t'explique un peu le
programme aujourd'hui on va commencer
par un homme boxing on va les ouvrir on
va regarder comment sont faites les
boîtes à quoi ressemble une première
prise en main on va comparer par rapport
à l'iphone 10 de l'année dernière vous
avez signé les deux boîtes sont
sensiblement sur une chose donc ça c'est
bleu qu'on va faire aujourd'hui on va
comparer ça ensuite prochaine vidéo on
va faire un test
on va faire un test complet on va le
discours est tous les côtés on va
regarder à la performance
on va regarder l'autonomie on va
regarder la différence entre les deux
modèles aussi le modèle leaf indice s et
l'iphone 10 s max on va vraiment testé
les 2 essayez de voir au final comment
ils vont alors je sais pas ce que je
ferais une vidéo pour l'un une vidéo
pour l'autre ça je vais voir en fonction
de l'utilisation je vous dirais on verra
comment on fait
et ensuite on va faire une autre vidéo
où on va se poser la question car ils
font d'acheter entre l'iphone 10 de
l'année dernière et les fun dit c'est de
cette année dans sachant que l'iphone
disque de l'année dernière n'est plus
disponible sur le store d'apple mais
vous pouvez trouver dans notre bonne
boutique voilà donc on va regarder est
ce que ça vaut le coup ou de switcher
sur ce modèle si ça vaut pas le coup est
ce qu'il faut rester sur l'ancien site
oui ou est ce qu'on peut trouver à quel
prix voilà toutes les astuces autant ça
va être cool eh bien on fait encore une
autre vidéo on va se poser la question
de la photo et de la vidéo parce que ça
mérite quand même de passer un petit peu
de temps dessus
lequel est le meilleur quel rendu pour
quoi faire comment quoi combien
à tout ça donc aujourd'hui on va se
concentrer sur le hand boxing on va
râler tout ça je suis super content
parce que en plus de ça on va parler
d'autre chose j'ai reçu tout à l'heure
un autre colis avec lui me disait de
proue alors on n'est pas du tout sur la
même chose mais c'est timide et six
aides de croo on va le tester et on a
ici son petit frère c'est le humide y
gisait de don va faire aussi deux vidéos
là dessus utiliser de une dizaine de
pros peut-être une troisième vidéo
utilisée 2 vs une dizaine de pros comme
ça on verra lequel acheter si ça vous
intéresse il ya beaucoup de choses ici
donc ça c'est plutôt cool mais
commençons par le commencement on va
commencer par ouvrir ces deux petites
boîtes
je sais pas vous mais moi la première
chose qui me saute aux yeux quand j'ai
vu même lors de la présentation
ces deux nouveaux iphone c'est
qu'effectivement on ne voit plus du tout
dans coche alors qu'elle est pourtant
bien là alors que sur le modèle de
l'année dernière l'encoche et elle a
très clairement vous pouvez pas la
louper
là vous avez un visuel qui est
extrêmement esthétique mais l'encoche
n'apparaît plus et donc on a vraiment
l'impression d'avoir un smartphone
complètement bord à bord et ça pour le
coup c'est très très très très fort de
la part d'apple
grosse grosse différence entre ces deux
iphone forcément on n'a pas le même
gabarit
d'un côté le dissès max de l'autre côté
le dissès les boîtes se ressemblent
énormément forcément même glaudel vous
allez toujours chapple un côté très
pratique pour l'ouvrir la petite
languette on va commencer par le 17
bon gré comme ça effeuillage très
pratique 10 s max c'est exactement la
même chose
déjà ne serait ce que sur la façon
d'ouvrir on va vraiment ne serait-ce que
la conception du papier croyez moi pour
avoir un emballage plastique qui
souffrent de cette manière là il ya dû y
avoir une réflexion comment on va
l'ouvrir quelle manière on va l'ouvrir
ce que c'est facile ça s'arrache d'un
seul bloc afin de trouver plein de
petits papiers de tous les côtés et ne
serait ce que pour ça ça demande du
temps ça coûte de l'argent ça se paye
mais en tout cas c'est plutôt efficace
voilà les deux jolies boîtes design by
apple in california ils tiennent
vraiment à fait de dia effectivement
leurs smartphones sont montés en chine
fabriqués en chine mais ils sont
complètement conçu directement en
californie ça c'est vraiment le point
auquel apple tient beaucoup
bien évidemment on va voir exactement la
même chose
pour le deuxième modèle forcément plus
grands se ressent dans les règles de
l'art on va le faire revient tout
doucement
voilà le nouvel iphone l'iphone 10s de
2018 premières impressions je le trouve
très esthétique très bon là vous avez
tout le côté extrêmement brillant tous
côtés aspect métal qui est vraiment
magnifique
hyper hyper classe le design cette année
est vraiment le même que celui de
l'année dernière où vous le regardez
comme ça sur la face avant
je vous mets au défi de me dire lequel
est le modèle de cette année lequel elle
modèle de l'année dernière ils se
ressemblent énormément il n'y a vraiment
pas de changement majeur entre modèles
de 2017 et le modèle de 2018 termes de
poids car une chose je pense mais moi
aujourd'hui ce qui m'intéresse vraiment
c'est de découvrir les plus grands
modèles
le format est complètement différents
formats beaucoup plus ans dont beaucoup
plus de place sur l'écran d'un point de
vue esthétique j'ai repéré une seule
différence c'est là sur l'iphone 10,16
de cette année vous avez une petite
bande là sur les fans disent vous ne
l'avez pas et vous avez la même chose de
l'autre côté sur l'iphone 10 de l'année
dernière vous n'avez pas la petite bande
là sur l'iphone 10s vous avez la petite
bande là au niveau des hauts parleurs
vous avez le même nombre de trous ici
sur l'iphone dit vous avez ici vos
citrouilles
qu'est-ce que sur les fun 10s vous avez
ici trois trous ce qui permet de loger
cette petite barre là sur le plus grand
modèle vous retrouverez également la
petite barre de différenciation contrat
son sein plus grand modèle de tout de
suite mais vous avez aussi la petite
barre l'aeo vie des trois trous vous
avez quatre trous la prise en main on
est sur un iphone 10 ses standards
effectivement là c'est un petit peu plus
grand en france on ne fait plus des
portes ouvertes
néanmoins le bout se trouve très
facilement le bouton ici pour venir à
l'allumer pour l'éteindre
on a un accès très rapide au bouton ici
pour monter pour baisser le volume
le bouton ici aussi pour couper le son
format un peu plus compacte sur l'iphone
10 aces mais j'aime bien les deux ce qui
est très marrant si vous regardez sur
l'iphone 10s vous avez en eau la partie
avec votre chargeur et vos écouteurs
sont bien dans le bon sens et tandis que
sur l'iphone 10 s max c'est carrément
inversée dans l'autre sens telle façon
industrielle donc j'imagine que c'est
pas une erreur très marrant toi que ce
soit fait
de cette manière alors à l'intérieur on
va retrouver bien évidemment son petit
lob de charge ces écouteurs filaires
toujours avec le port lightning de port
jack n'existe plus depuis un bon petit
moment déjà là dessus on a ensuite à
l'intérieur son câble usb vers port
lightning cette année a complètement
disparu de la boîte l'adaptateur port
jack black moon si vous le voulez il
vous coûtera 9 euros et quelques
accessible directement sur le site
d'apple voilà ça il faut le savoir
d'ailleurs je lui en ai parlé dans une
précédente vidéo à mon avis le calcul
est très simple de la part d'apple est
très malin on ne met pas à l'accessoire
qui coûte en termes de production donc
ça coûte plus cher à m à l'intérieur si
vous le voulez vous allez devoir lâcheté
donc ça leur permettra de gagner de la
marge
en plus donc un produit que vous aviez à
l'intérieur sur un smartphone premium
qui coûte 1000 euros voire plus si
affinités pour que vous n'avez pas si
vous le voulez il faut l'acheter ça va
générer du chiffre d'affaires du
business en plus et un peu plus de marge
plutôt malin de la part d'apple et
l'autre pointe extrêmement malade la
part d'apple s'est dirigé les
consommateurs vers des casques sans fil
en bluetooth notamment les casques beats
n'oublions pas que bitz a été rachetée
par apple
donc si vous êtes mordu à peu et vous
voulez un cast apple signé apple c'est
le casque beats vous allez l'acheter en
plus voilà c'est tout un écosystème tout
un business et toute façon c'est très
bien qu'apple serait l'entreprise
philanthropique
même si effectivement on peut pas leur
enlever ils font des choses pour la
lutte contre le sida notamment avec red
ils ont des actions ça c'est très
américain aussi mais on peut pas leur
enlever ce côté là ils sont là aussi
pour faire du business d'une entreprise
ils sont là pour gagner de l'argent
c'est le but même si les produits sont
très bien voilà ça c'est la parenthèse
on leur ferme on a également à
l'intérieur de la boîte
le petit allô bonjour à l'eau les
autocollants à la pomme d'apple
ici rien de bien des cônes en quelques
petites infos sur l'iphone pour vous
expliquer comment ça marche
bon normalement tous les consommateurs
aujourd'hui salle à peu près utilisent
un smartphone mais pour les personnes
qui pourrait débarquer dans l'univers du
smartphone toujours être bien y avoir un
sens de la voirie si vous avez bien
évidemment votre petit picot pour venir
on vient voir tiroirs de cartes sim qui
se loge juste là on a une petite pomme
on a une plus grosse pomme de l'autre
côté
hello hello la configuration est
complètement hallucinante il se connecte
directement d'un iphone à l'autre ça
prend le coût en terme de techno en peut
dire ce qu'on veut c'est hyper hyper
hyper efficace en termes d'expérience
utilisateur s'est complètement bluffant
ici mon iphone 6 sg transférer six sur
iphone 10 aces et la chansonnette sur
iphone 10 s max vole un peu pour la
partie un dock singh est aujourd'hui
donc bon c'est un smartphone qui marche
bien et fayçal dit il et les roues
extrêmement rapidement vous connaissez
après les iphones disent je veux pas
vous apprendre tout fonctionnement
l'oeil en train de télécharger toutes
mes applications de me remettre tout le
système à plat donc ça c'est cool jeunes
autistes à fond les fans disent s max
l'iphone 10 s
on va donc pouvoir les comparer
exactement de la même manière tous les
deux donc ça c'est plutôt cool j arrive
donc à faire une chose c'est à vous
abonner à rester connectés parce que
vous allez voir on va en parler on va s
il doit vraiment quelle est la
différence entre ces deux produits
les gabarits bien évidemment est ce
qu'il y à d'autres différences et je
vous dis on va faire le comparatif avec
le modèle de l'année dernière voir le
cruel et le plus cool de moins cool le
plus intéressant en france une vidéo sur
la photo la vidéo enfin plein de choses
l'eia ne point qu'il y est important et
on n'a pas encore abordé quand vous avez
des smartphones de cette qualité là et
de ce prix là c'est super important de
les protéger et pour les protéger
je vous conseille de prendre du matos
donc là il ya plein de matos qui m'a été
envoyé par rino shield très très très
très très très très important de
protéger vos smartphones si vous voulez
pas avoir des déconvenues
si vous voulez pas qu'il soit abîmé
qu'il casse chose comme ça c'est du
matériel qui est fait spécialement pour
les iphone 10 16 17 max
donc là on a plein de trucs super cool
vous pouvez mettre des boules peur comme
vous avez là vous prenez votre iphone
10s vous venez le mettre à l'intérieur
et là ça vous le protège tout autour
donc ça c'est plutôt pas mal
au moins à minima vous avez tout une
protection sur le contour et ce qui est
super bien et si par pratique avec celle
là c'est que vous pouvez complètement
les customiser je monte j'adore ça par
exemple cette partie là elle est
constituée avec leur hymne
vous avez donc plein de couleurs
différentes en faire comme vous voulez
qu'on va prendre par exemple le orange
ci vachement bien parce qu'après c'est
de la déco est permis de le customiser
parce que c'est vrai que souvent les
coques sont peu tristounette lapointe
coup c'est vachement punchy vascons
vivant et très très sympa en plus de ça
vous avez des boutons qui sont
personnalisables ans il pouvait glisser
votre smart
à l'intérieur et là vous avez un truc
hyper personnalisé avec des boutons de
couleurs pour lâcher un petit peu fort
en termes de déco mais après vous faites
ce que vous voulez parce qu'au final ce
qui est cool c'est que vous avez toutes
les couleurs là vous avez plein de
finition au niveau du rythme donc ça
c'est cool c'est pour la partie bumper
si vous voulez jouer un petit peu plus
or vous avez les solides sur un peu plus
standard qui vont très très bien vous
venez vous prenez votre iphone dedans
vous le positionner ça vous protège
votre iphone et ça je vous le recommande
parce que vous avez quand même un
smartphone qui coûte 1000 euros voire
plus de 1000 euros c'est très très très
très très très très important de les
protéger vous d'ailleurs le ternois tout
de suite pour éviter tout problème comme
ça au moins ils sont protégés
vous avez une jolie coque effet carbone
et ça c'est plutôt cool
autre nouveauté de rhinau fils ça vous
intéresse c'est le câble lightning usb 1
m 20 à peu près la taille de mon fils
voilà fort sympathique si tous ces
accessoires de rhinau chine vous
intéresse il un code promo pour les
acheter à moindre coût je vous ai mis un
lien dans la description et si ses
nouveaux iphone vous intéresse vous
aussi mis un lien en bas dans la
description comme ça vous pouvez y aller
vous faire plaisir
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui pour
cette vidéo de prise en main et
découverte des nouveaux iphone iphone 10
s iphone 10 s max on va les tester dans
quelques jours je voulais dire varie de
prendre on va les secouer tous les côtés
on va regarder par rapport à l'ancien
haras des la photo la vidéo à regarder
surtout si ça vaut le coup s'il faut les
acheter par rapport à d'autres modèles
sur le marché
est ce que ces nouveaux iphone 2d mais
des huit sont intéressants oui ou non
d'un culte en continuant à être iphone
10 r ça on verra plus tard vous invite
donc à baisser tous vos commentaires dès
maintenant pour poser vos questions
dites moi ce que vous voulez que je
taise de quelle manière si ça comme ça
je veux vraiment aller lescouët tous les
côtés et voir au final ce que ça dit
vous ne marquez tout ça comme d'hab
jolie table et ses commentaires tout ce
que vous voulez en bas j'y réponds je
vous envoie des messages
merci à vous soyez sages genre à se
chauffer
[Musique]